Matthew: Good afternoon!
I'm Matthew Spalding, Associate Vice-President
in Dean of Educational Programs for Hillsdale
College here in Washington, D.C.
Welcome!
We're at Allan P. Kirby Center for Constitutional
Studies & Citizenship.
Hillsdale College was founded in 1844 by men
and women believing that the diffusion of
learning is essential to the perpetuity of
the blessings of civil and religious liberty.
We take learning in those liberties very seriously.
It was George Washington in his great 1790
letter to the Jewish Congregation in Newport,
Rhode Island, the Jewish people being one
of the most persecuted peoples in history,
who reminded us that Americans enjoy their
religious liberty not as a matter of toleration
but as an exercise of inherent right found
up in man's very nature.
In rapidly changing times like these, we are
reminded how important it is to secure and
strengthen our first freedom.
We're very pleased to have our speaker with
us here today.
He'll be introduced by one of our students.
Sarah Ankin is from Seymour, Indiana.
She's a junior at Hillsdale College where
she is a Politics and Math Double Major.
She is a George Washington Fellow and currently
interning at the Heritage Foundation.
Sarah.
Sarah: Thank you, Dr. Spalding.
Good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and welcome.
As a born and raised Hoosier, I am very interested
in our speaker's talk this afternoon on the
War in Indiana.
Me and my friends, family members, classmates
and professors fiercely debated the controversy
over Indiana's Religious Freedom and Restoration
Act, and left some of us irritably divided.
It's my pleasure to introduce Mr. David French
who explained this issue and outlined what
it means for religious liberty in Indiana
and our country.
David French is an attorney, writer and veteran
of the Iraq war.
He's a graduate of Harvard Law School, the
past president of the Foundation for Individual
Rights in Education, and former lecturer at
Cornell Law School.
His legal work defending religious liberty
on college campuses helped inspired the 2014
hit movie, God's Not Dead.
A writer with national review, Mr. French
is also the author and co-author of several
book including A Season for Justice, Defending
the Rights of the Christian home, church and
school, and Rise of Isis: A Threat We Can't
Ignore, a New York Times number one bestseller.
He contributes regularly to Patheos and his
work has also appeared in the Washington Post,
Washington Times and Human Events.
French has appeared on ABC World News Tonight,
CNN Newsroom and Special Report with Brit
Hume.
A regular guest on radio talk show programs,
French has been interviewed with National
Public Radio and by numerous hosts including
Michael Melved, Hugh Hewitt and Dennis Prager.
Mr. French is a major of the US Army Reserve.
In 2007, he deployed to Iraq as a Squadron
Judge Advocate for the Second Squadron, Third
Armored Cavalry Regiment, and he was awarded
the Bronze Star at the conclusion of his tour.
He lives in Columbia, Tennessee with his wife,
Nancy, and their three children.
Please join me in welcoming Mr. David French.
David French: Thank you very much.
First, I want to thank the Kirby Center in
Hillsdale for inviting me.
It's a real honor to speak on this topic,
especially to folks in the audience, who just
looking at the audience, I know could deliver
an extended and better a lecture on this subject
than I can.
I want to begin where most discussions of
important cultural issue should begin and
that is with a Michael Bay and Jerry Bruckheimer
movie.
Some of you may remember this one, a classic,
called Armageddon.
Armageddon, if you forget the premise, was
that the world discovers that it is about
to end ... I think that's the premise for
most Michael Bay and Jerry Bruckheimer movies,
and it's going to end at the hands of a gigantic
asteroid or meteorite that is hurdling towards
the earth and will create a cataclysmic extinction-level
event.
The only way to stop it is to send a group
of deep core drillers, oil wildcatters out
to space led, of course, by Bruce Willis to
drill through the asteroid, plant a nuclear
bomb, detonate the asteroid, and come home
to safety and heroes' welcome.
Fantastic film.
The reason why it applies is I was trying
to think of an analogy for how the culture
war of a religious liberty is shaking out
and I couldn't think of a better analogy than
the process of mining.
The most vivid movie I can ever remember about
mining was Armageddon.
If you remember it and no doubt you do, they
landed on an asteroid in horrific conditions
after enduring many troubles, and they began
the process of mining.
They feel like their home-free.
They are cutting through soft rock for minutes,
for hours, they're on schedule.
Then what happens?
They hit some kind of hard space rock.
Their drill bits break, chaos occurs, people
die, and at the very end of it, Bruce Willis
has to sacrifice himself to save the world.
What does it have to do with religious liberty?
I would submit to you that for some time the
Left in making progress, in damaging religious
liberty in this country has been drilling
through an awful lot of soft rock.
It has been going through a public that is
largely unengaged to church, largely uninformed
about their reason for their values, heavily
swayed by pop culture, and ready to receive
a message that is simple, that is compelling,
and that casts a certain group of people in
white hats and a certain group of people in
black hats; easily susceptible to things like
race analogies; easily susceptible to changes
in perception by viewing, for example, sitcoms.
How often has anyone heard that one of the
most important developments for gay rights
in the United States was the sitcom, Will
and Grace?
I would submit to you that if a sitcom is
changing your world view, you are soft rock.
Where I live in the south, a soft rock is
lime stone.
Lime stone crumbles easily, drilled through
easily, but then sometimes when you're drilling,
you hit granite.
You hit hard rock.
I believe that the reason for the intensity
of the Battle of Indiana, which is only one
of many battles, is because the soft rock
has been stripped away and the cultural Left
is now encountering the granite of the base
of the cultural right, and it is not making
progress.
I could say, if there would be one subtitle
to this talk it would be "Against Despair".
The soft rock has been stripped away, the
granite remains, and now they are the ones
who are carrying the baggage of an easily
swayed sitcom-watching, sitcom-influenced
population, whereas we are now increasingly
pairing down to a base million strong of people
who are not willing to budge on core issues.
Not willing to budge at all, and in fact,
they're willing to push back and push back
decisively.
I didn't look at Indiana the way many people
looked at Indiana as a defeat for cultural
conservatism.
Unquestionably, there was a element of political
defeat.
Governor Pence and Indiana Republicans revised
the statute post-haste to try to deal with
popular objections that really had very little
basis in law or fact.
The Left declared victory.
They'd won a political battle there.
They had won what appeared to them to be a
PR battle, but there were deeper realities
there that I'm going to talk about.
Here are four truths that I think are emerging
as a result of the Battle of Indiana and many
other battles that have gone before and the
battles that will come after.
First, this is not a battle between "gay rights
and religious liberty"; it's just not.
It is a battle between the sexual revolution
in orthodox Christianity.
I would also include other religions as well,
Judaism, Islam, but the focus of the battle,
the focus is on the Christian community.
It's a battle of sexual revolution versus
orthodox Christianity.
Second, because increasingly, Christian thinkers
and the larger Christian public is realizing
that orthodox denominations and orthodox sectors,
small, low, of course when I'm using the term
orthodox, are not looking to revise or amend
or change their policies and their practices
and their theology surrounding sexual revolution
issues.
They're not.
Name one major American denomination that
you would consider evangelical or orthodox
that is thinking about revising, for example,
or seriously debating revising whether or
not it's going to recognize same sex marriages;
or revising whether or not it's going to support
abortion on demand.
There's not one.
It's not on the horizon.
Third, and part because of this, rather than
retreating quietly, cultural conservatism
is showing an enormous amount of strength
at the grassroots level.
Not at the pop culture level, not in the level
of the mainstream media, not in major coastal
cities, but at the grassroots levels it is
showing an enormous amount of strength.
Fourth, and this is vitally important as well,
the intellectual backbone of the conservative
movement in the United States is not wavering
on these key issues.
From the folks at the highest purchase, for
example, Ross Douthat at the New York Times,
the folks who are writing broadly about it
at multiple other publications, you were seeing
an enormous amount of unanimity that's what
is happening, for example, in Indiana, what
has happened to Hobby Lobby, what has happened
to Chick-fil-A, what has happened to Brendan
Eich, a large degree of consensus amongst
significant thinkers in the conservative movement
and in the Christian movement, more broadly,
that this is wrong, this is bad.
You'll have a lot of divergent as to whether
or not doom is upon us.
There's I think an emerging consensus often
that doom is upon us.
There's a word that Rod Dryer has mentioned
several ... or phrase he's mentioned is the
Benedict Option.
A strategic retreat from the culture.
I disagree with that and I'll discuss that
a little bit.
I believe those four principles are in play.
The good news means, with those four principles
in play, defeat for those who are interested
in religious liberty and advocate for religious
liberty is not imminent.
Here's the bad news, neither is victory.
I hesitate to use war analogies because what
we have here, thankfully in the United States,
is not religious war, it's not.
I especially hesitate war analogies and persecution
analogies given the fact that what's happening
overseas is horrifying on a scale that dwarfs
anything that we're experiencing as a result
of battles like Indiana or fights like Hobby
Lobby endured.
You can't really compare those two.
Having said that, I'm going to go ahead and
use a war analogy because they can be vivid
and instructive.
I think what we're beginning to go into is
a period of trench warfare, of essential stalemate
where the two bases clash with each other
again and again with not necessarily persuading
each other at stake, but persuading the softer
middle, that limestone that I talked about
to mix the metaphors.
Before I dive deeper into those four truths,
let me just set the stage for this battle
of Indiana.
For almost everyone in here, this is going
to be old hat, so you can tune out, you can
check your iPhone quickly and surreptitiously
if you want.
Let's just get some truth into this debate
about Indiana, specifically.
Indiana's law, its version of the Religious
Freedom Restoration Act, was not in any way
shape or form an attempt to reimpose Jim Crow,
nor was it an attempt to create a Jim Crow-like
regime for gay and lesbian citizens of Indiana.
It was not.
It was a law very much like a law that existed
that time in 19 other states and the United
States government that said that you can't
quite simply, that if there's a substantial
burden on your religious liberty, that burden
cannot be overcome by a state action unless
it's justified by compelling government interest,
accomplished with the least restrictive means.
That's a legal test.
It established a legal test, nothing more,
nothing less.
It just so happen to establish a legal test
that did not fall out of the clear blue sky.
It is a legal test that has existed for generations
in American law, in generations applied specifically
to religious liberty.
It's a legal test that existed simultaneously,
and this is very important to note, with the
explosive growth of non-discrimination statues
in the United States.
That legal test comes from the Supreme Court
of the United States, which at the same time
that the court was expanding its protection,
and was pioneering constitutional doctrine,
and upholding protections against race discrimination.
It was also implementing a test for the free
exercise clause of the first amendment that
was the compelling governmental interest test.
Those two legal developments existed side
by side.
On the one hand, if you're going to infringe
on religious liberty, you had to justify it
with a compelling governmental interest, you'd
at least restate your means.
On the other hand, we were in the United States
enacting huge numbers of public accommodation
statutes, non-discrimination statutes at the
federal and at the state levels.
In fact, the Supreme Court in 1968 in a footnote
talked about a conflict, claimed conflict,
between religious liberty and a public accommodation
statute that prohibited discrimination on
the basis of race, and declared in that case,
Newman versus Piggie Park Enterprises, 1968,
that a business owner's claim, they're decision
to exclude African-Americans from their business
was justified by their faith was "patently
frivolous".
That's the actual phrase that the Supreme
Court used, "patently frivolous".
If anyone says that the compelling governmental
interest standard supports and protects Jim
Crow, ask an answer.
Ask an answer.
What was at stake in Indiana?
It was not the ability to engage in class-based
discrimination, but rather the creation of
a legal test that on a case by case basis
could potentially protect religious liberty
in circumstances that are not acceptable to
one or other side of the political spectrum.
In the example of Indiana which caused an
enormous amount of controversy, that test
would involve, say for example a decision
to not provide a wedding ... Let me be precise
of Indiana, a pizza not provide a pizza to
a wedding reception for a same sex marriage
even though, for example, that pizza owner
would be happy to provide pizza to a wedding
of a gay man if the man were marrying a woman.
There was not class-based discrimination.
It was an unwillingness to participate or
to cooperate and to facilitate a ceremony
that the pizzeria owner found to be objectionable.
That's one kind of situation where RFRA could
be raised as a defense.
It would not necessarily decide the outcome
of the case.
The outcome of the case would depend on the
application of a legal test.
Was there a compelling governmental interest
to override the pizza owner's conscience?
If there was, was it accomplished with the
least restrictive means?
Anyone who thinks that a case under that test
on those facts is a foregone conclusion as
to how it would come out, is not familiar
with the practice of law in state or federal
court in this country.
Legal tests do not provide automatic outcomes.
They just don't.
On the other hand, when many people on the
Left really liked RFRAs, it involved such
more exotic religious practices such as smoking
peyote.
In fact, the right to smoke peyote in a religious
ritual was the motivation for the first and
grandest RFRA, the Supreme Court of the United
States struck down or reversed itself on its
compelling governmental interest standard
when it received a case from a person who
sought the right to smoke peyote in a religious
ritual.
The Supreme Court in a highly controversial
decision at the time said, "We're going to
change our test.
We're going to essentially say religious liberty
claim fails if it collides with a neutral
law of general applicability," which pretty
much swallowed the free exercise clause.
There was a by-partisan reaction to that decision
that resulted in the National Religious Freedom
Restoration Act that reimposed that test originally
on both state and federal laws, but the Supreme
Court narrowed it down to just federal laws,
and that was what issued at the Hobby Lobby
cases.
This was about a legal test.
It was not about Jim Crow and it was not about
guaranteeing that a Christian baker or florist
could refuse to serve a gay wedding, because
not even the architects of the bill could
say that that's what would occur.
That would have been up to a court.
This was about much more than the facts.
This was about symbols.
It was about the symbolism of the sexual revolution,
possibly maybe, facing a small legal and political
reverse.
Small, because let's just face it, how many
bakers and florists have refused to serve
in gay weddings, or photographers?
I think I can count four to five.
Last time I counted, I think the population
of this country is about 310, 315 million.
To say that this would be a significant reverse
for sexual revolution, if four to five people
might could possibly win a case in refusing
to participate in a same sex wedding, that's
your fantasy.
Symbols matter and symbols were important
and so the Battle of Indiana was launched.
Here is where I think the debate has begun
to change in my professional life.
The first time I ever worked on a religious
liberty case was I was a 1L at Harvard Law
School.
It was the fall of 1991.
I was incredibly excited that a lawyer had
asked me to proofread a brief filed in a case,
and this is maybe the greatest case name ever.
I can't even remember the plaintiff's name,
but the defendant was Hot, Sexy and Safer
Productions.
The facts of the case were pretty amazing.
In this Hot, Sexy and Safer case, students
were required to attend a student assembly
and at that student assembly, this was high
school, there were people engaged in simulated
sex acts on stage who urged students to experiment
sexually.
They placed condoms onto bananas.
They did all kinds of things that you've heard
about in other cases and other places.
Some Christian students objected to this and
one of them tried to stand up to leave.
He was physically pushed down into his seat
by a school official.
Physically pushed down and made to continue
to watch it.
They filed a claim and I thought, "Wow!
Outrageous!
America will rise up in anger at this violation
of individual liberty.
The courts will be outraged."
The case received approximately no press attention
and the student's case went down in flames,
lost at the trial court, lost in the first
circuit.
To this day, as far as I know, it was a good
law you can require students to attend these
assemblies, witness these events that are
morally objectionably to large numbers in
the students, and they may not leave.
They're not constitutionally entitled to leave.
Then I continued on in my practice.
In the year 2000, I had an interesting case
at Tufts University.
This was one of my first cases when I had
left the work of the large law firm.
I was a lecturer at Cornell Law School at
the time, and a friend of a friend called
and said, "I have a problem at Tufts University."
"What's the problem?"
"My student group got thrown off campus in
an emergency meeting of the Student Conduct
Board."
"Why?"
"Well it turns out that we would not let an
openly lesbian woman become president of the
organization."
I thought, "You've been thrown out on an emergency
meeting.
What was the emergency?"
Follow this logic, the Student Conduct Board
met and decided that Christianity teaches
there is such a thing as sin.
Are you following me so far?
A sense of sin leads to feelings of guilt.
Are you with me?
Guilt leads to feelings of shame, including
deep shame.
Shame leads to ... Who wants to fill in the
last blank?
Suicide?
To protect the campus from suicide, the InterVarsity
Christian Fellowship at Tufts University had
to be thrown off campus post-haste.
I got involved in that case.
That case by at least what I thought as a
much younger lawyer, exploded in the media.
I thought this is a turning point.
Now, Americans will realize there is a problem
that we're facing with the religious liberty.
If a Christian student group cannot decide
that it would be led by a Christian.
That's a problem.
Mainstream media covered it and PR covered
it.
Everybody covered it.
I thought this is a fantastic turning point.
Eventually, the Student Conduct Board reversed
itself, allowed InterVarsity back on campus.
In my naive younger days, I thought what a
tremendous victory.
I was right, it was a victory, for the other
side because all of a sudden, campuses around
the country said, "I have an idea.
Let's go on a search and destroy mission for
organizations like InterVarsity that have
similar policies."
My friend, Kim Colby, and I have been fighting
this for a very long time.
We put together a list recently and these
are the cases that just Kim and I have been
involved in, and I stopped counting at 35
states and more than 100 individual institutions
where Christian student groups have either
been exclude from campus or threatened with
exclusion because they wanted leadership to
be Christian.
The battles kept going and I could go through
fact scenario after fact scenario after fact
scenario where again and again I would believe
if I pounded the table enough, if we yelled
loudly enough, if we put the right kind of
industry and attention into this issue, then
finally, the base of conservatism, the base
of Christian conservatism, the base of faithful
Christians would understand the stakes and
begin to respond.
Little did I know that going after campus
Christians wasn't the straw that would break
the camel's back.
Going after elementary school children wasn't
the straw that break the camel's back.
Silencing chaplains wasn't the straw that
would break the camel's back.
I can go on and on.
The straw that would break the camel's back
is when they came for our chicken sandwiches.
When Chick-fil-A faced the wrath of the so-called
social justice warriors, all of a sudden the
sleeping giant awoke.
I think that that was an important lesson
for those of us who deal with the public day
in, day out on these issues is that we're
really not that big a deal.
We can have 15 million talking head appearances,
write 1,700 op-eds and talk about this day
in, day out, but there's nothing more powerful
than a good meal to really motivate people.
There was the largest anti-sexual revolution,
grassroots movement I've ever seen in my life
and may ever see when hundreds of Chick-fil-A
stores across the country sold out of their
chicken.
Never heard of a restaurant selling out of
its food.
My wife went to the "buycott" in our local
town and there was so much traffic that the
police officer was directing it with a big
Chick-fil-A cup in his hand to make sure that
there wasn't a traffic jam in Columbia, Tennessee,
which would have been the first ever non-meal
day related traffic jam in Columbia history,
and yes, we have a meal day.
Every local politician was there joining in,
"Me too, me too, I'm for Chick-fil-A."
It was an astonishing cultural moment.
It was also a valuable cultural moment because
it began to penetrate into the popular mind
of the Christian community, the conservative
community, more broadly in this country that
there's something serious going on here.
That's why when I say "It's not gay rights
versus religious liberty.
It's donning on people this is sexual revolution
versus Christianity."
If you'll note every time there is a major
confrontation, pop culture confrontation on
these things, the Left narrows the issue.
Wendy Davis filibusters and she is the queen
of defending the right to choose, then it's
all about this very narrow issue of the state
legislature intruding on women's body.
Hobby Lobby, it's involved in a massive confrontation
leading to its own attempted and utterly failed
boycott from the Left against Hobby Lobby.
There it's not about a larger sweeping thing.
It's about can women get contraceptives.
In Indiana, it's not about anything bigger
and sweeper, it's about this very specific
gay rights versus religious liberty.
Are you going to mistreat this gay couple
who wants to get married?
Again and again, the focus is let's make this
small.
Why are you doing this discreet action that
hurts women or denies contraceptives or denies
a gay couple the pizza they so desperately
want at their reception?
This discreet action that the larger Christian
community is beginning to understand this
is linked.
This is absolutely linked.
It's about an overriding world view that is
not biblical.
It is anti-biblical.
That folding onto one element of it requires
by theological logic, folding on every element
of it.
I would urge you guys to read in the Atlantic,
Ross Douthat has a piece about Pope Francis.
He talks about how the Catholic Church is
facing right now this question about what
to do with couples who are divorced and remarried.
On the one side, there is an argument that
it's a very discreet decision that you can
grant communication to a remarried couple
without doing violence to the larger structure
of Catholic theology on sexuality.
On the other side is the argument that this
is part of a seamless hole, and that if you
tear away one part of it, the theological
logic there is so relentless, you'll tear
away the rest.
That argument is winning the day in orthodox
denominations and churches around the country.
That is why when you look at the Southern
Baptist Convention, when you look at Catholicism,
when you look at capital or orthodoxy, when
you look at evangelical non-denominational
churches, denominational churches around the
country, you're not seeing any movement on
this issue.
Instead, the argument is not how do we accommodate
the culture, the argument is what is the best
way to present our argument back to the culture.
I was just in a meeting with Russell Moore
at the Ethics & Religious Liberty Commission
in Southern Baptist Convention.
As everyone knows, Southern Baptist Convention
is the largest Protestant denomination in
the US, roughly 19 million plus people affiliated.
In question of the day wasn't how do we accommodate.
The question of the day is how do we persuade
about the truth of scripture.
When you have the largest denomination in
the United States, the Protestant denomination
focused on changing hearts and minds to its
position, it is not a time of gloom and doom.
Not a time of gloom and doom at all.
That I think is leading directly into the
growth of the grassroots movement that exist
against totalitarianism, against conformity
in the sexual arena and the diminishment of
religious liberty.
I mentioned, of course, Chick-fil-A that's
legendary by this point, but let's also not
forget Hobby Lobby.
Hobby Lobby was supposed to pay for its sin,
of paying for only 16 out of 20 contraceptives.
It was going to have to pay for its apostasy.
It did not pay for its apostasy.
Instead, Hobby Lobby would not only won at
the Supreme Court of the United States, it
won on busily serving its customers who by
and large ... I think it won maybe second
or third largest store in my meal capital
of the world after Walmart is a Hobby Lobby.
If you ask their customers, "Should these
folks whose store they patronize is full of
Christian symbols and imagery and Christian
books, including books by the founders of
the company that proclaim their Christian
faith, should they be forced to pay for pills
and devices that they believe cause abortion?"
They would say no, absolutely not.
I wouldn't want them to, so boycott utterly
failed.
I bring up this example and I bring it up
now because I agree with everything Phil Roberston
says or how it says it, but the effort to
drive a guy, I knew the Left is beginning
to lose a bit of its cultural power when it
lost in an effort to drive a guy off its own
medium, television, a mainstream cable channel
for engaging in a speech against homosexual
activity that was pretty colorful and upfront.
They lost that battle.
He's still there.
He's still there to this day even though ... I
can't even open and read the Huffington Post
any given week without reading about a "fresh
outrage" from Phil Robertson, but he's still
there.
They lost on that.
Think about this, in Texas, recently there
was an effort to subpoena the contents of
not just sermons but communications with parishioners,
between parishioners and pastors about sexual
issues.
Unbelievably overreaching.
Legal organizations stampeded in to file to
quash those subpoenas, but the public outrage
was so great that even a radical city government
in Houston capitulated maybe within 24 and
I think no later than within 48 hours.
Something is happening at the grassroots that
is very potent and very powerful.
Let's not forget Indiana.
In Indiana, two of the headlines were "Republicans
Cave", which sad to say ... Is that Tuesday?
Republicans Cave on multiple conflicts frequently,
as do Democrats.
Compromise is part of politics.
The headlines were "Republicans Cave", "Memories
Pizza Closes Its Doors".
This pizza company that had received death
threat, an avalanche, a negative Google and
Yelp reviews closes its doors and then says,
"We don't know when we're going to be open,"
lest well-covered in the media was what happened
next.
They lashed and the folks of the Blaze initiate
a go fund me campaign, which for a small dollar
donations they helped reopen Memories Pizza.
It raises, before they closed it down, $850,000
in less than a week.
Now, some of you guys here are involved in
non-profit fundraising effort.
I try raising $850,000 in small dollar donations
in less than a week without a pre-existing
mailing list, without a pre-existing affiliation
with the organization ... I mean, that an
astonishing accomplishment.
Astonishing.
They would have kept going had they not shut
it down.
Memories Pizza did what, it reopened to a
packed house.
While the headline was Politicians Cave, the
grassroots reality was Memories Pizza, this
vilified organization prevails, and now they're
rich.
I had no idea that small town pizza could
be so lucrative.
The grassroots came through.
This brings back to reaffirming the last point
that I mentioned.
As the grassroots comes through, the intellectual
core of the conservative Christianity, of
conservatism more generally, remains intact.
It might be despairing.
In the Game of Thrones, winter is coming sort
of starkey and worldview, but it remains intact.
As I mentioned earlier, Ross Douthat has been
writing invaluable stuff at New York Times.
Many people in this room have been offering
their own contributions dismayed by the drift
of the culture but not yielding on the underlying
principles involved.
I would submit to you that history would show
that where the grassroots remains intact and
the intellectual core of a movement remain
intact, the politicians will follow.
Rare is the politician who's a true leader.
They tend to be followers who follow their
culture; the culture that they come from.
A great example of this is the pro-life movement.
For a very long time we'd had a real difficulty
making progress on life legislation, but in
recent years, as the grassroots movement in
the states has grown in power, we have seen
much of the abortion industry chagrin, more
pro-life legislation enacted say in the last
three years than the previous 10 combined.
That's a result of politicians who are following
a culture that is energized on this issue,
and an intellectual core that also has always
been energized on this issue.
Again, this sounds like I'm being optimistic.
I'm just predicting stalemate.
In predicting stalemate, that strikes some
people as wildly optimistic.
Here is where I think we can begin to turn
from stalemate into progress.
As I mentioned earlier and then I'm going
to open this up for questions, the reality
is particularly within the religious community,
that the argument, the sexual revolutionary
argument is failing, is failing to appeal
to people of faith.
It just is.
If you look at the denominations that have
opened their doors, who have proclaimed that
they have opened their theology to a variety
of beliefs and practices that defy orthodox
Christianity, they're vanishing, they are.
PCUSA, I just mentioned them not because of
any long-standing grudge since I'm part of
the PCA and we were split off from them, but
if you compare the growth of the PCA with
the losses of the PCUSA, which last year loss
5% of its total membership and more than 100
congregations in one year, with the PCA, which
has had 10-fold increase in the last 20 years,
you can see where the energy and momentum
is.
The mainstream media would tell you otherwise.
A closer than example of this that we've seen
in my own backyard in Tennessee.
Not too far from where I live is a evangelical
church called Grace Point Church.
It's a church that a lot of musicians like
to attend.
It's Carrie Underwood's church if you remember
Carrie Underwood of American Idol fame and
Jesus Take the Wheel fame and many other great
songs.
I think I have four of her albums.
I'm a Carrie Underwood fan.
She attends this church and it's long been
known as a "gay friendly" evangelical church.
About three months or so ago, it took the
plunge and became the first "big" evangelical
church in Nashville to say, "We're going to
recognize same sex marriages."
This was covered in Time Magazine.
It was a big event.
This is the crack in the wall of evangelical
churches.
It's a mega church in Nashville.
Now, for less than 1,000 members, that is
not a mega church in Nashville.
I can show you a mega church in Nashville.
City blocks of just churches.
At the very end of the article in Time, it
noticed that they had already lost almost
50% of their members in two weeks time after
announcing they're embracing same sex marriage,
and almost 50% of donations.
Just two weeks ago, the church, what used
to have two and sometimes three services on
Sunday morning, launched just one service
called "Together in This", signaling I think
that they now believe that it's them against
the world, that so for Christian organizations,
recent history is proving the path to cultural
accommodation is the path to extinction.
That if you look at the list of growing or
holding firm denominations in entities in
the United States, it is those who maintained
adherence to orthodox Christianity.
Granite, by definition, is strong.
Limestone, by definition, is much weaker.
We have born down to the granite and now it
is time to regather our strength and try to
make headway again back into the limestone.
With that, I'm happy to take your questions.
Speaker 4: Hello.
My question for you is on the very nature
of religious liberty.
I'm not entirely convinced that's the right
argument.
I'm just wondering if you could fill this
out.
There's almost an assumption of total state
power to regulate private contracts that the
only way you can get out of that is by using
sincerely how the religious believe.
In my mind, have we already lost the battle
by accepting this dichotomy that the government
really does.
It occupies the public square and the private
square.
There is no distinction.
The only way to get out of it is through religious
belief.
I'm just wondering if you could comment on
that.
David French: I think that the religious liberty
argument is a nice segue into a larger discussion
of who owns a business.
One of the things that struck me about the
Hobby Lobby argument was that in fact, just
what you said, the only real argument that
they had available to them was the religious
liberty argument under RFRA.
That was the only viable legal argument, certainly,
and the one that prevailed at the Supreme
Court, but it led to a larger conversation
that needs to occur about who really owns
the business.
We have reached the point where with through
voluminous economic regulations, health and
safety regulations, public accommodation statutes,
that there is almost this assumption that
people have that if I'm in a for-profit business,
I have essentially no rights if my desire
to run my business in a particular manner
conflicts with the government's desire to
regulate me.
I think the Hobby Lobby case was a cultural
moment to begin questioning that premise,
but I would agree with you.
I think that it's quite distressing from a
liberty standpoint that the only real viable
argument left to the Hobby Lobby owners was
that religious liberty argument, and had it
not been for RFRA, they would have had a very
difficult time in court.
Yes.
Speaker 5: I'd like to invite your comments
on the Benedict Option and specifically, I'd
be interested in which legislative protection
do you think would need to be enacted first?
David French: Let me describe to you what
I think the Benedict Option is because it's
a new concept.
The Benedict Option as I understand it is
a strategic withdrawal from pop culture, culture
at large, retreating into your specific church
organizations, retrenching and reteaching
the truth of scripture and the church.
Then once you have resolidified at an indefinite
future date, you're going to sally back forth
into the culture.
Is that a fair description?
I have two problems with that.
One, tactical and one, legal or it's tactical/strategic,
also with theological elements thrown in.
Number one, teaching properly within churches,
the eternal truths of Christianity is something
that should be the baseline of what we're
doing already.
I think it's a bit of an exaggeration to believe
that we're not given the solidity of the various
major denomination on these core issues.
I think that's already occurring to a greater
degree than many may perceive.
Second things is if you begin to consciously
adopt that Benedict Option and retreating
back to the church proper, you're inadvertently
beginning to play into an argument that the
Obama Administration and other Left had been
making is that religious liberty is the thing
you do in church.
If you retreat back to church, you're giving
a cultural argument that yes, in fact, that
is where religious liberty occurs.
It is in church.
One of the, I think more subtle and damaging
aspects of the entire debate over the HHS
mandate, was the extent to which well if you
are in a church plan, with a church organization,
you were fine.
Move along, nothing to see here.
All part of this effort just redefined religious
liberty as the "right to worship" when religious
liberty is really something much more broad.
Finally, I think that the Benedict Option
in my mind is inconsistent with the call to
be salt and light.
There's many different ways that you can do
that.
There are ways subtle, ways that are overt.
One of the more fun and I used that term sarcastically,
debates in the larger Christian community
is over.
Which forms of Christians art that they're
really good forms of Christian art to sally
forth into the culture?
You have on one side, the people are saying
that the very explicit religious communication
like say, God's not Dead, that's the way to
go.
Others say, "No, no, no, no.
That's just heavy-handed and nobody likes
it.
It's like 3% in the Rotten Tomatoes.
We're going to go with the much more subtle,
cool, hipster way to do it."
I'm of the mindset of do it all.
Do it all.
Be direct, be subtle, but be salt and light.
I feel like the Benedict Option and I don't
think Rod would say he doesn't want to be
salt and light, but I think that one of the
implications of that is a retreat is inconsistent
with that salt and light imperative.
Yes.
Speaker 6: I want to play Devil's Advocate
pointing to I think three facts, if they are
facts, that might undermine optimism 00:46:08.
I agree we should be hopeful but I think hope
is different than optimism.
David French: Keep in mind my optimism is
of a stalemate.
Speaker 6: Sure.
Here are three facts I want to raise.
I think you're right that the denominations
that are growing are orthodox but what's not
clear to me that the members of those denominations…
is actually being lived out.
It's also true that the official teaching
of the Roman Catholic Church in the United
States is good on these things and the official
teaching of the Southern Baptist Convention
and of all of its members, church was they're
good in this.
What are the actual beliefs of Southern Baptists
and Roman Catholics?
What are their practices?
If you look at their premarital sex rates,
their divorce rates, their online pornography
watching rates, what would those look like
compared to the general.
It strikes me that the sexual revolution has
been much more toxic and has infiltrated even
the best…to a much greater degree than what
merely citing which denomination is growing
and not growing…
That's one problem.
We highlighted this a couple of years ago
by saying that the only reason the formal
legal redefinition of marriage… is because
so many heterosexuals have already bought
into that vision.
The vision of marriage that says marriage
is about consenting adult, romancing, caregiving,
and consenting adult should do whatever consenting
adult want to do has already informed the
moral imaginations of many heterosexual and
many conservative groups.
OK.
That's just fact one.
Fact two is that you point to the intellectuals
and you kept citing Ross ... this is a question
that challenges thesis.
This is how these things work.
Point two would be that the only intellectual
you cited was Ross Douthat.
I didn't see any intellectual in mainstream
organization, whether a newspaper or a university
besides Ross Douthat, Robby George that defends
Christian orthodox as true.
David French: Michael Gerson.
Speaker 6: I don't think if he defended as
truth much as I saw a lot of religious liberty
defenses.
This goes back to the first question.
I saw a lot of libertarians saying, "Christians
should be free to have their silly beliefs."
I didn't see many people at major mainstream
institutions saying those beliefs are true.
David French: There's not many Christians
in major mainstream or institutions to make
that point.
Speaker 6: I don't know about that.
We could throw that off line but I would say
there are a lot more ... We saw this in Rod's
blog saying orthodox Christians at elite institutions
that couldn't speak out for fear of losing
tenure.
David French: Wouldn't speak out.
Speaker 6: Unless they ... wouldn't speak
out.
David French: Wouldn't speak out.
Speaker 6: You see this most concretely in
the political class right now in DC.
A party dedicated to freedom and liberty will
not move to defend their religious liberty
at private religious schools in the District
of Columbia.
All these when you put it together, it doesn't
action.
David French: You said three things.
Number one, there's a difference between self-professed
adherence to a faith and church-going members
of the faith.
Russell Moore has done outstanding work on
this that we need to get past this notion
of, also for example, depending on the measure,
50% of Americans are evangelical or 40% or
30%.
No, no, no, no.
The community I'm talking about is the community
of church-going faith.
I would urge you to look at some and I can't
cite URLs for you right now, but Russell Moore
and his team at the ELC have done a really
good job showing that the distinction in America
is not between professions of identity, "I'm
an evangelical or I'm not an evangelical,"
as between those people who are church-going
and not church-going.
Church-going evangelicals divorce a heck of
a lot less.
Their behavior on every major element that
you brought up is significantly different
from the culture at large.
When I talk about that, I'm talking about
the church-going public, which is still millions
upon millions strong.
As much descent as there is and there is certainly
descent within any orthodox denomination,
there is a more decent right now in the main
line as the churches are peeling off every
single time, they make another step down the
road of the sexual revolution.
That's covered much less.
Grace Point makes Time Magazine.
How many of the hundred plus PCUSA churches
that left the PCUSA in 2013 made Time Magazine.
That's another story, but it is a story that
one moderately sides the evangelical church,
that was point one.
Number two was ... Yes, what I would say is
I can't think of a single significant public
intellectual that is a orthodox Christian,
who has while there might be some who've changed
their minds about the legality of whether
gay marriage should be protected legally or
not, who've changed their mind on the underlying
theological position that same sex behavior
is immoral.
I can think of Rob Bell or a Brian McLaren,
but respectfully, they don't count as leading
conservative or orthodox thinkers.
I would say there's a paucity of them in New
York Times, there's a paucity in the Washington
Post, but that's honestly not where the orthodox
community gets its news or its ideas, by and
large.
I feel like Rick Perry magnified the third
one.
Oh, right.
In that point, I'm going to agree with you.
This isn't just the religious liberty point.
I mean we had the House failed to pass a 20-week
abortion ban giving the abortion industry
a victory on the day of the March for Life.
You're not going to find in me ... and I'm
going to say I don't want to cast as a class
Republicans in this way.
There are members of staff and individual
congressmen and senators who are doing great
work; no question.
There are also many others who lag on that.
One thing I'm going to have to agree with
Rodger Aaron is he called governor of Arkansas,
a Republican Walmart, that there is an enormous
influence from corporations that are opposed,
who have taken one side in the culture wars.
I don't have a lot of short-term optimism.
Politically, I have long-term optimism and
I use this as an example for that, the battle
for life.
Even though we stumble here and there, bottom
line is in the last three years, more pro-life
legislation than in the last 10 combined.
That's very positive.
Yes, Brian.
Speaker 7: David, I hear you urging us to
particular battle, much larger front.
can you tell us what that mindset in Indiana,
organizations, lots of businesses versus
David French: I think we have towers the strength
outside the beltway.
For example, just to think of Becket Fund,
ADF, I mean ADF is a $50-million organization.
Becket Fund, I don't know its budget but it's
staffed top to bottom with lawyers who just
win at the Supreme Court is what they do lately.
We have institutions that are very, very powerful.
Our institutions though are communicating
to different audiences.
The Alliance Defense Fund or comparable.
They're not going to receive the same kind
of attention from the mainstream media except
in a negative way that the human rights campaign
will receive.
It creates I think a false impression if you're
just parachuting in and glancing at the media
as to the strength of the respective sides.
I think you'll get a more accurate perception
of the strength when you begin to look at
more objective measures.
For example, almost a million dollars for
this little pizza company.
That's an objective thing that occur that
isn't a pop culture, just a subjective sense
of who won and lost a day of political debate.
That's real dollars and cents.
I don't deny their strength in the mainstream
media.
I don't deny the strength of their institutions.
All of those budgets are magnified many times
and their power by the sympathy of say New
York Times or Washington Post, ABC, NBC, CBS,
CNN, the list goes on.
We have strength as well and that strength
is one real significant victory.
I'll give you another example I think of where
we've began to see some movement and some
retreat in the areas where the Left has felt
that its strongest and that is in higher education.
The California State System has excluded in
a varsity and a number of other groups from
campus.
This is the heart of deep blue California.
If you look at the coverage of that decision
for that past year, it has been far more negative
than positive towards health stake.
There's some possibility and hope that there
can be some positive outcomes there as a result
of that.
The situation at Gordon College when it first
endured its wave of persecution.
I hate to use the word persecution.
Its wave of negative publicity and actions
in Massachusetts was very isolated and alone.
As it became known, what was happening to
Gordon, there's been significant support for
the institution including and to be fair to
Republicans, from the Hill.
That support, I believe, bearing good fruit
in its own battle.
There are instances where even in the heartland,
the heart of the Left, the higher education,
there's some reason for some optimism that
we are making some progress.
Yes.
Oh, I'm sorry.
OK, thank you, guys.